there has recently been a lot of talk
about apple working on a virtual reality
headset
which could be used for vr gaming but in
my opinion
i don't think a lot of people are gonna
buy it and i'll explain why in just a
minute
i'm also gonna be discussing my
experience with the oculus quest
2 vr headset which is the best
mainstream gaming headset so far
but before i get into that let's go
through the history of apple vr headset
leaks and rumors
way back in 2008 over 12 years ago
apple was reportedly researching a
laser-based head-mounted display
but since the tech was so old back then
it relied on using an
ipod and a compact laser engine that
attaches to your
belt so this shows that apple's been
interested in head mounted displays
for many years now way later in 2013
apple was granted a patent for a
goggle-like video headset
designed to allow users to view media
while on the go
there was even an image of a cable
connecting an ipod to the headset
and that's because the patent was
originally filed in 2008
then in 2015 apple hired on a small team
working on augmented reality projects
with the goal of creating a wearable
device
only two months later apple acquired the
augmented reality startup
mittayo which focused on building
virtual reality experiences
and then in 2016 apple hired doug
bowman a lead virtual reality researcher
who actually worked on a bunch of
different headsets like the oculus rift
microsoft hololens and even google glass
and just a few days later it was
revealed that apple had a secret team
working on a virtual reality headset
with hundreds of employees
exploring both vr and augmented reality
and apparently they had already built
prototype vr headsets
which were inspired by the oculus rift
and that was way back in 2016.
two years later the vr developer studio
named servios
stated that apple is putting a lot of
effort and passion
into virtual reality including vr gaming
a little bit later it was revealed that
the youtuber mark rober
was actually helping apple work on an
anti-motion sickness vr technology
headset
for use in the future autonomous apple
car
the point was that the car would be able
to drive itself so you can kick back and
enjoy some media
using a vr headset while you drive to
work
which honestly seems like a dream come
true if it actually ends up working out
but unfortunately
mark rober confirmed that he left that
position
in 2019 and a year later apple filed a
new patent showing that they're still
interested in this vr headset technology
meant to battle motion sickness by
creating an immersive world
with a virtual environment and now
finally in 2021
we just got a bunch of specific details
on what to expect from apple's vr
headset
so let's get right into the new leaks
and rumors a couple of weeks back
mark german reported that apple's first
virtual reality headset
will be a pricey niche precursor
to a more ambitious augmented reality
product it'll display an
all-encompassing 3d digital environment
for gaming
watching video and communicating with
apple launching it
as soon as 2022 apparently the price
will be far more expensive
than those from rivals with apple not
really expecting to sell that many of
them
so it'll be a high-end niche product
like the mac pro
the report also says that apple plans to
pack in higher resolution displays
in the headset than those in current vr
offerings
which might explain the high price and
it's also supposed to get
much more powerful chips than even the
m1 chip in recent max
mark even says that apple could include
a fan in the device pointing to a ton of
graphics performance being built in
now on the other hand apple is also
working on augmented reality glasses
codenamed n421 which could be released
as early as 2023 and apple was also said
to be working on
hand tracking features like typing on a
keyboard in mid-air
and just two days ago we got another
report from the china times
about apple's vr headset releasing in
the first quarter of 2022
with lidar technology which is already
in use in apple's iphone 12 pro
and their ipad pro the report says that
the design of the headset will look very
similar
to that of other vr headsets jpmorgan
believes that this headset will be
targeted at the top end of the consumer
market
being more expensive than other vr
headsets
with the device's materials also
exceeding 500
which shows that apple could be charging
big bucks potentially over a thousand
dollars for this headset
and just yesterday we got even more
details
and this is where it starts to get very
exciting but also
very disappointing the information
reported that apple's upcoming vr
headset
is said to feature dual 8k displays
yes not one but dual 8k
displays this is insane because the
current most popular oculus quest 2
headset
features dual 2k displays and in my
experience
it actually looks pretty good and i'll
get to that in just a minute
running dual ak displays means that you
would need a ton of graphics performance
or some kind of upscaling technology so
it would make sense why it would come
with a built-in fan
from that previous rumor the headset
will apparently compact with more than a
dozen cameras
for tracking hand movements with some of
the cameras tracking eye movements
within the headset as well and
apparently the cameras will record the
environment in front of you
and pass it on through the display so
you can get a mixed
reality effect the information said that
they actually viewed a late stage
prototype
which showed a sleek curved visor
attached to the face
by a mesh material and with swappable
headbands
so i wonder if it's the same kind of
mesh used in the airpods max
headphones apparently you can also swap
out the headband
based on what you need like having
spatial audio technology
or additional battery life there will
also be multiple ways to control the
headset
including a thimble-like device worn on
a person's finger
or of course eye and hand movements
and there could be a dial on the side of
the visor which will probably be a crown
like on the apple watch
now here comes the crazy part they said
that apple internally discussed
pricing the headset around a massive
three thousand dollars which absolutely
blows my mind
but apparently microsoft's hollow lens
two
is also very expensive at thirty five
hundred dollars
so it might try to compete with that
that microsoft headset is a very niche
product
meant for high-end professional use so
it kind of seems like apple's headset
might be going the same route if this is
true but based on all the features that
i just mentioned
like having over 12 cameras and a dual
8k
displays it makes sense why it could be
so expensive
and that right there is the main reason
why most people will
not be buying apple's vr headset because
even if apple
significantly drops the price from that
three thousand dollar estimate
it's still going to be way too expensive
for most consumers
even at a thousand dollars it's overkill
for most people
because the current best vr headset the
oculus
quest 2 is only 300 on amazon
and most people should honestly just buy
that instead
it basically offers a complete vr
headset in one package
with a comfortable headband built-in
speakers and
decent displays the two and a half hour
battery life is just enough for a long
vr gaming session and you can use a
battery bank if you need more
there's a wide variety of available
games like population one
which i really enjoyed since it features
a battle royale style map
and really nice gameplay but my favorite
game was
beat saber and i was impressed with how
well the controls and tracking worked
so i've got to say that the oculus quest
2 is the first
vr headset which is actually great and
at its 300
purchase price it's affordable to most
people
being cheaper than a ps5 or an xbox
series x
now i know that apple's vr headset will
be the mother of all vr products
and it might even revolutionize virtual
reality
but i think if it's priced at anywhere
near two or three thousand dollars
i don't think most people are gonna be
interested so there you guys have it
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did
tap the like button below click the
circle above to subscribe
check out one of those two videos right
over there thank you guys for watching
and we'll see you in
the next one